[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Joel Klatt Fox Sports lead college
football analyst was on the call at the
Rose Bowl USC the win and uh Michigan
and Ohio State will be his next game and
he also started a new football podcast
called the Joel Klatt show Joel joins us
on the program Joel the best win this
weekend was turned in by who
oh I think it was I think it was USC I I
know that there were some upsets right
so South Carolina obviously that's a
that's a great win over Tennessee but
but when you think about USC needing
something bigger on their resume they
had beaten Oregon State people were
wondering whether they could you know
figure this out with maybe a defense
that wasn't a great defense I think that
that stage for Caleb Williams the win
for Lincoln Riley and then to set
themselves up for a path towards the
playoff and maybe even controlling their
own destiny to the playoff I thought
that was the biggest win of the weekend
you know obviously I was rooting for for
Michigan and Ohio State pacing around my
room I was like come on boys we gotta
let's get to 11-0 but but I think the
biggest one was was USC uh the worst win
of the weekend was turned in by who uh
Alabama 34-nothing over Austin P you
know and and listen I've been critical
of this and it's not an SEC thing and
it's not even necessarily a knock at
Alabama it's more about the structure of
the sport that we
have
allowed the the sport to be controlled
by so many different people in terms of
schedule making
um schedule complex that we have these
these cupcake games in in November now
listen I understand that these games are
going to take place I would just rather
them take place in September and the
reason is then as you know like once you
start getting into the grind of a season
it just is difficult you know Health
becomes a factor all these teams that
struggled or lost to teams that maybe
they shouldn't were struggling with
their health you know whether it's the
running back room at Ohio State or
Michigan now with Blake Quorum uh TCU
was banged up uh Tennessee obviously
gets hinned and uh knocked up in that
game Hendon Hooker Hooker which I feel
awful about
it's difficult and and also these are 18
to 22 year olds and you're trying to get
them to play at their best week in and
week out that's just a difficult
standard to get these guys to try to
uphold every single week and then the
last thing about it I think is that in a
sport in which we still
rate review and reward championships
based on subjective review I think that
winning against Austin P 34 nothing in
November
is brushed off as just like okay that's
fine if that was week one we'd be like
what's wrong with Alabama
right so you can rest you don't have to
win great and and you get to play that
game or even you know UAB for LSU any of
these type of like cupcake games so so
that's a long-winded answer to a simple
question when does tampering start when
when do you get the the you know these
coaches or intermediaries to reach out
to somebody to say hey uh we're gonna
need a quarterback at Tennessee next
year or yeah you know how this goes when
when does that start
it's an interesting way you phrased it
because in my mind the first thing that
I think of is
for it to start that means that it stops
at some point
you know right so but there's not a
portal window that you go from this to
this because it feels like things have
to lead up to the transfer portal
yes and and so the the portal there are
some more guidelines now right like this
year it's a little different you can't
just enter the portal at any point and
so December 4th I believe is the date or
fifth maybe it it is where the port the
portal opens and so there's this thought
that it's like well there's going to be
no tampering until the you know until
the portal is open and then it's legal
because then you can contact and recruit
these kids I think if if we if we
believe that then then we all should be
you know buying up the ocean from
property outside of Flagstaff right
because then we're all gullible
tampering is happening inducements are
happening
um and and I I think that it is the
worst unintended consequence of What
were well-intended new changes to the
rules I think that the transfer rule is
well intended it's been obviously you
know misused at times nil
I've been arguing for nil for a long
time since I was a player
um by the way I played with Jeremy Bloom
at Colorado you know so I had played
Minor League Baseball I could go back
and I was fine I was eligible but he
couldn't be a skier which was you know
it was it was crazy so I've been arguing
for nil for for a long time but Dan when
you mix all of this together then you've
got what the landscape that we currently
have where there's a lot of tampering
there's inducements there's all these
things and there's rules on the books
that are supposed to curtail this type
of behavior let me just pose a like a
question back I would say
isn't it more about enforcement
right and and the governing bodies
actually going out and enforcing the
rules that are existing and and I think
that that's an important piece of what
college football should be moving
forward and it can't be in retrospect
hey two years ago you had you know X Y
and Z violation I'm talking about in
real time do you know why the NFL is the
NFL and some people love this about it
some people hate it they have real-time
enforcement you don't wear your socks
high enough bam it comes out of your
game check and and I believe that the
coaches in college football are now
making enough money
right that we should be finding coaches
it's not about vacating wins or doing
something like a show cause you tamper
with a player it's a million bucks
right now
and now I'll show you a bunch of coaches
that will govern themselves and so I
think that if we just
shift the way we talk about enforcement
of the existing rules I think that we
could get some of this stuff under wraps
he's Joe clatt he'll be on the call for
Michigan on Ohio State and he started a
new podcast it's called the Joel clatt
show
let's look at the scenarios let's say
Ohio state would lose to Michigan
hmm close game
Ohio State's still a top four team
after that
I yeah I think I think that they would
be
um I think at that point the the two
biggest issues that that Ohio state
would have or or I would actually say
pluses for them is that Notre Dame is on
this great late season run Penn State uh
after the two losses to Michigan and
Ohio State have has been terrific so all
of a sudden their resume looks really
good okay
um and with Tennessee losing
I I think that they would still be a top
four team if Ohio State were to lose I
think Michigan's a different discussion
if Michigan loses close game
I think it's going to be tough I think
that you're going to have to I think
Michigan would need some help I think
that they would then they would probably
need USC to lose uh at some point and
they would need TCU to lose and it would
help them if TCU lost actually in the
championship game so rather than like
let's say TCU lost this week but still
won the big 12. that would because the
committee is supposed to honor
conference championships so they would
need I think a loss from USC or TCU in
their conference Championship game and
then you can start to make an argument
and then that argument becomes more
focused towards Clemson and and less the
other two and I think that's an argument
that you could look favorably on the
Wolverines there is a a scenario and a
path in particular in the close game
you're talking about we'll Pretend We're
to get potentially two teams this year
where is Deion Sanders coaching next
year
that's a that's a great question I've
heard a lot of rumors about a lot of
different places I I know Dion is happy
where he's at he's obviously built
something very special they're going to
play for their conference Championship
game
um
I think if if I had to bet I would say
he stays where he's at Dan if I had to
put money down and and I thought I I had
said earlier in the year that I thought
it was going to be Auburn uh it doesn't
look like that's going to be the case it
won't
listen it won't surprise me at all if he
takes a job or someone makes a run at
him here but I do know uh those close to
him have said he is laser focused on the
season that he's having and in
particular this Championship run that
he's going to be having that will finish
on December 3rd yeah I wonder you don't
take a job to take a job you take the
right job for you and he seems very
calculated if I am leaving I want to
make sure that I'm successful not go
into Nebraska where you know that might
take a while uh Auburn you know jumping
into the SEC you know I know that
previous year that he interviewed for a
few jobs and and didn't get those and
then didn't even get his alma mater
Florida State
so I I'm guessing that if he if he stays
it's because he doesn't see the correct
uh right opportunity for him now but
that doesn't mean he's going to stay at
Jackson State you know for a long period
of time yeah and it doesn't it seem like
and I was Saturday night I was I was I
was explaining the Spider-Man meme to
Gus I don't know if you caught that and
he was like what does that mean and I
was like I don't even know it's just a
bunch of Spider-Man's pointing at each
other like I you know but it does feel a
little bit like that amongst power five
schools right now like everyone's just
staring at each other thinking to
themselves
who's going to do it you know who's
going to pull the trigger he's going to
be a power five coach at some point I
firmly believe that and he's proved his
Acumen as a head coach this is not a
novelty bit you know Dan's a really good
coach that team is a very good team he's
a he's an excellent recruiter
um he's a great leader you talk to
people around Jackson State and the
things that he does away from the
cameras uh are are really good and
strong and have foundation so he's going
to be a head coach I firmly believe that
and I also think it's interesting the
way that he views the coming landscape
of an expanded playoff
um you know I've been talking with a lot
of people within the sport and they've
been talking about you know I think that
jobs even outside of the Big Ten and SEC
while they might not have the the the
revenue share that the Big Ten and SEC
has there could be an easier path to the
playoff as it expands so I think that
the the way that we view jobs might be
a little behind right now and and as it
relates to I think that'll be an
interesting piece to this of what what
he views the the coming landscape of the
sport to be and where he thinks he can
have top-end success Jimbo Fisher's safe
that's a great question
listen if I'm signing checks yes because
that's not that's that's not a check I'm
willing to sign hey
I don't know I I gotta be honest like I
would have said all year Dan that like
yeah they're not gonna do that they
can't do that but it's gotten to a level
now where the toxicity within the
program
um is you know is so bad now is it so
bad that it's 85 million dollars I'm not
sure and Jimbo's got all all the
leverage there I will say this about
Jimbo he just hasn't adjusted think
about the great coaches even in the last
decade they've adjusted at some point in
their career right like Nick Saban is
winning a very different style and using
a different offense and he's adjusted
from what he was when he first got to
Alabama Ed ogeron did that with Joe
Brady and brought in Joe burrow Bob
Stoops did that when he hired Lincoln
Riley uh Urban Meyer did that when he
brought in Ryan day uh Mike belotti did
that back at Oregon when he brought in
Chip Kelly we we see this time and time
again where guys adjust and we haven't
seen that from Jimbo Fisher that's what
he needs to do his his staff is going to
need to change it drastically and then
this is also a case study then and like
is it is it good for your team your
locker room to just go out there and and
do what we all suspect happened at Texas
A M yeah yes you get a number one
recruiting class but did they come for
the promises or did they come for the
place and and that's a question now
you've got a lot of coaches that are
sitting there and they're thinking to
themselves do I really want to commit
nil dollars to guys that have never been
in my locker room yet because the case
study at Texas A M is is pretty Stark in
terms of it didn't work this year
if a player leaves
do I still have to pay them
how does nil work if is it a
year-to-year contract like a scholarship
is
well there there is no Rhyme or Reason
there's no singular
you know stock form we're not pulling
this out of the shelf and saying like
hey here's the nil thing like it used to
be with the scholarship right a letter
of intent so every one of these is
different I've seen Nils that are very
straightforward if you're here if you're
eligible you know this is this is what
the nil uh contract States I've seen
them come from companies and I've seen
them facilitated through the university
uh I've also seen third-party agents get
involved and start promising kids things
that are outside of the school or
outside of any entity that's paying
money saying like hey I'm going to
promise you I'm gonna go get these deals
and then in the fine print I've seen
this and this is where it's very sad
these players are signing away future
earnings you and I both know that that
happens in the NFL going towards the
draft but now it's starting to happen in
college football I don't think that
that's great for for these athletes or
their families so to answer your
question like there's no one way that
this is being done which is is why
people are so eager to try to get let's
say Federal legislation to try to put
some sort of guard rails around what
we're doing right now in name image and
likeness
I mentioned a couple of weeks ago that I
liked Caleb Williams for the Heisman
because I saw how this was going to play
out or at least I thought it was he was
going to be playing ranked teams you
know you've got UCLA then you have Notre
Dame you have the Pac-12 title game
those are all stand-alone games yeah and
CJ Stroud was going to have the Michigan
game the Iowa game and the Big Ten title
game is probably not going to mean as
much but but Caleb Williams has games
that are Notre Dame is Big the Pac-12 uh
you know title game and then what
happened against UCLA
we're running out of Heisman candidates
here Joel yeah I mean we got CJ Stroud
and Caleb Williams and I mean Blake
Quorum got injured so I don't know uh
hooker got injured I don't know are we
gonna have three guy four guys go to New
York here how do you see this I'm not
sure yeah and and by the way Drake May
who had some late run you know they lose
and he doesn't throw a touchdown and and
throws a pick in that game I think Max
Duggan is is maybe kind of in there and
has a shot to get to New York because of
how he played uh against Baylor last
week but you're exactly right I've
always said that that we always argue
about like is it most valuable player is
it most outstanding should it be a guy
that's on a worse team listen the
reality of the Heisman is it kind of
fits in three categories you got to be a
great player on a great team and then
you have to have what you're talking
about which is those moments on the
stages necessary late in the season to
get everybody's attention and and this
is one of the reasons why Derrick Henry
wins the high McCaffrey right McCaffrey
didn't really have those moments and
stages late in the season like Derek
Henry did when he was going off in
November and that great uh year so to
your point I if you look at the betting
markets CJ Stroud
is is right there as the favorite as the
Heisman favorite and then before last
week Caleb Williams was fifth now he's
second and a pretty clear second and
it's really just those two and so you're
looking at a situation where I believe
that the next 60 Minutes of football for
each of these players is going to
determine the Heisman trophy so you've
got Stroud against Michigan and what
will be an epic game with shoot I mean
at least we're hoping close to 20
million people watching these two
undefeateds and you've got the Notre
Dame SC rivalry with Caleb Williams
there's not a doubt in my mind that
Caleb is more valuable to his team than
maybe even CJ Stroud and that's not a
knock against Stroud it's just kind of
an Ode to what the roster is for USC
after last week I can tell you right now
that Caleb Williams is is transforming
to this incredible talent to a guy that
reminds me a lot of of a little like a
mahomes-esque quality when he breaks
contain he's such a threat throwing the
ball on the Run he's such a threat
keeping his eyes downfield willing to
make any throw and then does it with
accuracy
um you know he's going to be hard to
beat I think even for CJ Stroud if he
goes out there and they beat Notre Dame
and he throws for like 350 or 400 yards
and this is a Notre Dame defense by the
way past defense that is not bad eight
interceptions and only five touchdowns
given up in the last uh four games and
haven't had a 300 yard passer oh
actually only one this year and it was
Drake May from North Carolina I'll I'll
leave you with this thought on Drake May
in the final 30 seconds open market
if if there if he was on the open market
right now
just like Caleb Williams was
what is Drake May worth
oh
for one year yeah you can bring him in I
mean he's a redshirt freshman you might
get him for two ten
fifteen
right I mean like because if it works a
year then it's worth every penny
yeah
I mean think think about what what a
playoff run means to to a team to that
conference in terms of Revenue share but
let's say Tennessee they just lost
hooker I don't know what their backup
situation is but if Drake May wanted to
go to Tennessee
open market pay him 10 million dollars a
year I mean what we we saw so Tennessee
reportedly offered now it was over four
years but it was a somewhere between
eight and nine million dollars to a kid
coming out of high school that's gonna
sign and go there so if you're telling
me I can get a
a known commodity like Drake may I think
that that would be worth close to 10.
yeah and by the by the way and I'm not
saying that I don't like their backups
but if I'm Drake May and I hate just I
hate throwing this out there but real
quick Dan if I'm one of those great
quarterbacks Drake May I'm looking at
Marvin Harrison and being like Oh wait
he doesn't have a starter coming back
because that dude Marvin Harrison Jr
he's one of the best players I've ever
covered in college football
Drake Made to Ohio State
[Laughter]
10 million dollars hey you know who
knows yeah uh have fun this weekend and
thank you that tell Gus we said hello
thank you bud I will Happy Thanksgiving
guys that's Joe clatt
Fox uh college football analyst their
lead analyst who has Michigan and Ohio
State